I read a comment I you know I blocked
this person too because they were making
a comparison of like it's a dumb
comparison to say this right and they
were saying like oh why are you so
passionate about stuff it's like do you
think you should speak on stuff like
this it's not even your culture well
hold on a second let me let me just kind
of put this in perspective and this
might not apply to you but this applies
to me for sure right I always talk about
how I grew up the people that I've been
around the way that I speak though I
think the hard part and I'm not I'm not
speaking as a black black black male
yeah I think there's an Asian American
man it's a person of color too just on a
different spectrum it's annoying
for even me when I see this right hip
hop culture jazz pop culture all this
other stuff yeah you can see where this
source comes from right and everything
that's hip and cool actually comes from
a lot of black culture that a lot of
people imitate right right they take
they take they take here's how the
problem is and this is where I see it
this is how I see it right how can you
sit there every day sometimes these
people's brands their music everything
that they do their image how they speak
how they talk all comes with this black
culture they still and they take that
[ __ ] and they're cool with it but the
moment that you have to speak up on
stuff that's affecting that culture you
go
hey I'm not black it's not my business
all right how [ __ ] terrible is that I
think culture appropriation yeah it's
like you take and take and take but when
it's time for you to give back to a
culture that has given you so much
you're just like it's none of my
business
all right so now I so that's why if you
hear people say like you hear this anger
and also this annoyance with people
where they say like well you are you an
ally watch I'm not really big on that
term but I guess I'm just gonna use it
in this sense they go are you an ally or
not and I think that comes from a lot of
frustration of us like yo you [ __ ]
steal from black culture all the time
and we're cool with it right but now
we're getting [ __ ] over and you see
that [ __ ] and you're okay with it and
you just want to be quiet about it
because you're not black yeah but you've
benefited so much from this [ __ ] and the
crazy thing is that you have to
understand like a lot of this like cool
stuff that you see in black culture also
stems from their oppression they took
their [ __ ] lemons and they made
lemonade out of it and with that
lemonade we didn't have to deal with the
sour lemons we just took the [ __ ]
lemonade right and now we're cool just
drinking that [ __ ] to ourselves
all the [ __ ] time yeah without
lending help when they need it the most
that's why for someone like me because I
grew up in black culture even the way
that I speak the way that I you know the
way that I think the music that I enjoy
stands up a lot from black American
culture so for me it does affect me
right it does hurt when I see a black
male being having a [ __ ] knee to the
back of his neck it sucks when I see
Eric garner for selling cigarettes on
the side of a corner getting choked out
and killed sucks when I see a mod
jogging and he gets murdered it's
terrible for me because if I don't say
stuff like this right which I
technically yeah I don't have to but I
feel like I do need to because I am
somebody who partook in taking the
positives from this culture so when this
culture needs help I got to say
something
mhm you know yeah I mean and and the the
sad thing about it is it situations like
this always almost inevitably becomes
political right if you are showing
compassion you're getting called a far
left lip [ __ ] right yeah and if you're
justifying you know the act of the cops
then you're a nutjob right wing right
it's not about politics about this you
don't it doesn't matter whether you're a
[ __ ] Democrat liberal a Republican
like it's about human compassion you
know it's just about being a human being
ya know and you do not at your political
affiliation has no effect on you being
able to show compassion right
problem is though and and we touched
upon this on previous podcast is that
right now in this country man a certain
group of people are empowered you know
and these groups of people let's just
say don't aren't necessarily fighters of
equality yeah yeah they're they're not
exactly people of justice you know only
justice when it's convenient for them
not not not equal justice right
and it's like why why does why there's a
situation like this have to be so
divisive yeah you know again why can't
we start at the core issue which is a
human being died yeah right and and
let's let's at least have the
conversation from that point on but
people now are just so quick to be like
oh you you know you you have a just a
lived heart you know mindset you know
you you have the you know it's it's
strange to think about - because it's
like the fact that you're showing
compassion makes you a Lib [ __ ] yeah you
know so odd right yeah people kind of
just they put their political agenda in
this type of stuff yeah that's true like
I I do agree with you let's start with
the human side right and we're even like
I'll even bring it up like this where
yeah man I got man I was so disappointed
when the Asian dude was there I was like
Oh agent cop hole cut damage god no you
know and his name was like to tau or tau
tow right here like the most Asian name
ever meant I was like him I wish his
name was like Keith Keith powers or some
[ __ ] you know I mean it's like nah man
he's white he just looks Asian but this
dude had the most [ __ ] Asian name
ever dude how toe - yeah and so this
[ __ ] I think this is why I've
been trying to get a cop to come on here
right not because I wanted to attack
them I just want to know what protocol
is not so I could protect myself but I
want to know what it's like to be a cop
in those types